Jordan Peterson has expressed a few
concerns about Islam over the years for
instance there was the time he referred
to Muhammad as a warlord
Muhammad was a warlord
and I I don't know what to do about that
fact
fortunately Dr Peterson has apologized
for this islamophobic statement of
indisputable fact and you objected to my
we used to have the term warlord and
perhaps rightly so you know perhaps that
was an injudicious comment and he has
atoned for his hurtful but obviously
true Claim by promoting various Muslim
thinkers on his platform his tears sing
a song of true repentance
I'm happy to say that after a number of
Illuminating discussions with Muslims we
can finally hear a Kinder gentler
humbler more enlightened Dr Peterson
share what he's learned about Islam
molas how about no
I I don't buy your Ella
well this is awkward
you mean to tell me that after having
Islam carefully explained to him by
prominent Muslim thinkers he wants
nothing to do with the God who sent a
warlord as his final messenger
now I'm going to cry
but before I do let's take a closer look
at what Dr Peterson said because I have
a feeling that he might be on to
something here
indeed he might be ready to explain one
of the most significant differences
between Islam and Christianity
Dr Peterson warned the mullets of the
world about his contempt for their God
during his interview with Constantine
Kissin co-host of the insightful and
entertaining podcast trigonometry
Constantine is an agnostic who
nevertheless thinks that religious
beliefs can be useful Dr Peterson spends
no small amount of time trying to
convince him to take religion more
seriously let's jump into the discussion
with Constantine sharing his thoughts on
religion I believe religion is useful
right heartwarming and I I'm fondant I
can't remember who said this but someone
said that the poor belief religion is
true the middle class believes it's
false and the rich believe it's useful
that's a modified version of a quotation
often attributed to the Roman stoic
philosopher Seneca although there's a
bit of Doubt as to its origin uh I I'm
not powerful or Rich but I certainly
consider it useful and I can see that
the lack of it has its negative impact
as well as an ex-con who became a
Christian in a jail cell I understand
your perspective Constantine so you
believe that religion is useful why
don't you sign on
I just don't wish to submit myself to a
rigid ideology of that kind combined
with the fact I don't believe in the
bigger the guy in the sky Constantine
gives two reasons one he doesn't want to
submit to some sort of rigid religious
ideology and two he just doesn't believe
in God
so there's a matter of the will he
doesn't want to have to follow some list
of rules and there's a matter of the
intellect how could he convert to
something when he doesn't believe it's
true
a very interesting question is to what
extent are those two matters connected
in other words how much does the fact
that you don't want to submit to
something affect whether you believe
it's true but that'll have to wait for
another tongue for this part of the
interview notice that Constantine says
he doesn't want to submit
as many of you know the word Islam means
submission submission is the defining
characteristic of Islam watch where they
go with this
okay so let's not make it okay so let's
agree that you shouldn't subordinate
yourself arbitrarily to a rigid
structure don't submit arbitrarily to
some rigid ideology
agreed you might want to do that
sporadically to discipline yourself
right but the the object shouldn't be
submission deliberate temporary
submission to a rigid ideology can help
build discipline and self-control but
the goal shouldn't be submission again
submission is the defining Central
characteristic of Islam
but aren't all abrahamic faiths like
that Dr Peterson
now that what's weird in the biblical
narrative you know is that the the goal
is not submission
so weird it's covenantal relationship
covenantal relationship really not blind
submission
and covenantal relationship is actually
relationships so one of the things you
see with Moses for example and you also
see this with Abraham is that they're
constantly negotiating with God
Jordan Peterson is right the biblical
prophets had a relationship with God
it's a negotiation it's not a submission
he's really emphasizing that this isn't
submission God is always threatening to
wipe out the Israelites in the desert
he's just sick and tired of their idol
worship and their whiny resentment and
their bitterness and their worship of
the past tyranny well that kind of makes
it sound like he's demanding submission
and he's constantly threatening just to
wipe them out and start again
stop whining so much or I'll wipe you
out and start over
sounds like a call for submission and
Moses is constantly interceding on their
behalf and telling God he shouldn't
break his word and the odd thing in the
story is that God actually listens which
is rather Preposterous Dr Peterson says
it's Preposterous for God to listen to
Moses
but God listening to Moses is what shows
that there's a relationship involved not
simply blind submission but the reason
that's happening is to mitigate against
exactly the problem that you described
which is to have the relationship with
the Transcendent degenerate into nothing
but a blind obedience so it's weird to
think of God the Transcendent as
actually listening to human beings but
that's what's needed in order to avoid
the blind obedience that Constantine
doesn't like
now for the elephant in the room
if submission and blind obedience are a
problem
and then the danger of that is well a
blind obedience
to who we're not all prophets so if we
don't have a relationship with God and
we're just going to submit
someone's going to tell us
whom to submit to right
and I see this as a threat in Islam in
the more fundamentalist forms of Islam
it's like well you should submit to
Allah it's like hey fair enough
Ella as interpreted by who Allah demands
submission
but how do we submit to Allah
the Quran tells us we submit to Allah by
mindlessly obeying all of Muhammad's
decisions in Surah 4 verse 65 of the
Quran Allah declares
but no by your lord they can have no
faith until they make you o Muhammad
judge in all disputes between them and
find in themselves no resistance against
your decisions and accept them with full
submission
you can't have any real Islamic faith
until you completely submit to all of
Muhammad's decisions
but Muhammad's decisions are spread
through piles of Islamic sources
how do you submit to all of Muhammad's
decisions
you do what your mullahs tell you
what do you think of that Dr Peterson
Allah as interpreted by who oh uh
totalitarian misogynistic mullahs how
about no
the totalitarianism and misogyny are
kind of built into Islam so you don't
even need the mullus for this
totalitarian misogynistic molas how
about no
I I don't buy your Ella say what now
I I don't buy your Ella why buy when you
can rent
I I don't buy your Ella and I don't see
who made you the right precise and even
if I believe in the bearded guy in the
sky I'm not sure I need a middleman to
talk to him so Dr Peterson and
Constantine agree that there's a problem
in Islam Islam requires submission to
Allah how do you submit to Allah
you submit to Allah by obeying Muhammad
how do you obey Muhammad
the mullahs tell you how to obey
Muhammad
Constantine says he doesn't see why he
would need a middleman and then Dr
Peterson tells him what that suggests
about his personality
I'm not sure I need a middleman to talk
to him
right well that makes you a good
Protestant
the discussion goes on for a while
following his remark about Constantine
being a good Protestant Dr Peterson
breaks down the dangers associated with
the Catholic mindset and the Protestant
mindset if you have a priest or a church
as a mediator between you and God the
danger is that the priest or the church
can lead to a kind of authoritarian
rigidity Protestants rebelled against
that system but there's a danger here as
well
the danger of not having a middle man as
an authority is that each person can
become his own church
we can become too individualistic and Dr
Peterson connects that to some of the
problems we're facing in the west where
certain individuals are now convinced
that any thought or feeling they have is
somehow binding on everyone else as if
their thoughts and feelings are
infallible and authoritative
fun stuff so no matter which approach
you go with things can go off the rails
very quickly but the main takeaway of
this part of the interview was the
difference between Islam on the one hand
and Judaism and Christianity on the
other
Islam means submission and at the end of
the day that's all it is
there are definitely passages in the
Bible where God demands submission but
what you find is different kinds of
language that describe different
features of a relationship with God
there are passages where God is our Lord
and Master and we're his servants there
are passages where God is our King and
we are his subjects there are passages
where God is our father and we are his
children
there are even passages where God is the
husband or Christ is the husband and the
nation of Israel or the church is the
bride
so you have a multi-faceted relationship
with God
in Islam there's only one relationship
Surah 19 verse 93 of the Quran says that
the only relationship we can have with
Allah is a slave to master relationship
you can be a good slave in which case
Allah will reward you or you can be a
bad slave in which case Allah will
punish you
but that's all you will ever be to Allah
a Slave
so
let's stop pretending that all religions
teach the same thing
if Jordan Peterson and Constantine
Kissin can spot such a glaring
difference between Christianity and
Islam
why can't you atheists in the comments
section get the point
[Music]